[Musik]
okay okay
wir machen heute drei rezepte das ist
unser erstes rezepte machen montella
kreise dringend
hilfe benötigt ihr so viele zähler wie
ihr wollt und blätterteig also wir
nehmen uns erstmal jeder tag und holst
reise machen
wir uns jetzt einfach unser
kreis und dann drücken wir das so
und dann haben wir hier so einen kreis
was machen wir
ja
ich glaube ich könnte das alles also
eigentlich geht es ja jeder
dass erst recht zu machen bleibt dann
aufmachen
dieser moment
[Musik]
einfach drauf
ich kann es noch nicht probieren
diese mir gesagt probieren
das ist doch viel zu viel zu probieren
ich kenne leute die noch in das aber ich
kann das nicht
[Musik]
also wir haben jetzt noch was übrig also
dass er hier und wir wollen nicht dass
weggeschmissen wird deswegen machen
jetzt einfach sozusagen sticks drauf
so jetzt hab ich hier ein bisschen
gescheitert drauf gespielt aber nicht
sagen randegg ausläuft und jetzt wollte
ich es einfach so
also wir machen das jetzt so
dass wir hier so eck nicke rennen und es
nun fest drücken damit rand gibt
[Musik]
jutta helfen
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
ihr habt gesagt aber er macht euch echt
viel arbeit gastgeber bisserl einfacher
mit bindedraht den ranzen humboldt dann
habt ihr nicht so viel arbeit mit dem
ruhigen hoch machen und was weiß ich was
er braucht ist so viel not
ganz bei mir nur so weit bist du das
immer so schön hierhin geformt hatte
schichtarbeiter wird da was machen wir
noch und ich bin nicht immer und die
sonne kommt
bleibt da bleibt doch wir haben noch den
ofen vergessen
noch
offen verhalten nun ist der ofen
vorheizen ein offizier
seiner grad
christoph keller ein und super
[Musik]
also wenn ihr das nachmachen ihr braucht
keinen ganzen platz braucht ihr hotel
ascot kinder
dass ganz viele kinder schokolade drin
ist auch lecker schmeckt
lecker
ich bleibe bei meiner lotus creme gut
so jetzt kommt in den ofen oder an die
wir müssen noch an pinseln
doch als nächstes machen wir unser
zweites rezept
zu probieren ich habe noch nicht
getestet deswegen konstantesten
experiment wird ja so vieles rezept
brauchen wir eine bio-gurke 175 g
frischkäse 50 gramm lachs etwas zitrone
salz und pfeffer also ich mache jetzt
erstmal so
die grundlage und turbo abi macht jetzt
erstmal die creme dafür schneidet ihr
erstmal hin so ein bisschen ab auf
beiden seiten
und dann nehme ich mir einen großen
schiller zur hand und
jeder hätte darüber und ja
wie kommst du auf das rezept eigentlich
also ich hab einfach ich war halt auf
tik tok unterwegs und hab ich halt
einfach gesehen dass sie sowas nachdem
und bis jetzt ist es zeit auch trend
deswegen habe ich dir herzlich machen
und so steht er jedoch
nicht
willst du mich ein oder ist sein werden
und es muss man halt auch gut
aufeinander platzieren sag ich mal so
dann mit halt nichts ausläuft
[Musik]
was machst du damit ist natürlich
auch ein stück
so jetzt haben wir das hier schon so
hingerichtet
aber wir müssen sie jetzt erst mal noch
abtrocknen weil es ist noch etwas feucht
und dann fällt die prämie so gut
deswegen nehme ich mir jetzt einfach so
ein thema und wirklich drauf
und jetzt wollen wir unseren blick drauf
machen jetzt alles in der video
[Musik]
jetzt machen wir noch ein bisschen
räucherlachs drauf
[Musik]
so dann können wir von anfang an zu
rennen oder
let's go was machen die leute wo kein
max bemühten wir können uns ja mit
avocado oder sogar gute idee
also du musst bisschen fester
[Musik]
jetzt nehmen wir uns als stabilisierung
er teilt seine stocker dazu man kann ja
noch ganz mal daneben ja
und jetzt stecken wir das fürchten lachs
durch alles durch
das war's das war das problem mir
einfach nur ja aber was vergessen ja
okay wir machen wir jetzt schnell nach
nur
mit dir oder machen andere
selber machen und zwar wir haben hier
[Gelächter]
also willkommen jetzt eigentlich
auch dieses charakters trier acasuso
nehmen die gibt es tree was sie rat
tschuldigung dass sie roger
würde könne mitnehmen davon da gibt es
eine die ist
quasi mit majo schon gemischt aber wir
machen die uns das selber ja
eigentlich ganz einfach sich zu kaufen
ich brauche jetzt eins de
[Musik]
mayo und
noch ein bisschen so ja auch so
von dem scharfen
ja und dann nehmen wir noch vielen dank
noch eine limette
ein bisschen limettensaft das geht mir
auch noch mit rein
das reicht schon
die gehen jetzt einfach so ein bisschen
drüber
ich habe jetzt noch sesam und
kreuzkümmel und das mache ich das doch
ein bisschen drauf
und fertig ist ein sushi
doch darf jedoch kein
probieren
[Musik]
richtig lecker
zum probieren ein
paar sekunden später
[Applaus]
sehr gut selbst frisch auf kann man auch
bei so schön warm temperaturen schön
genießen
jetzt nach unserem nachzuschauen wir
vergessen
unsere nutzer legen wir sind jetzt schon
fertig und
nach probieren
[Applaus]
das ist ja die ganze dem hintergrund war
dass man dir
[Applaus]
alles alles also ich sage euch eins da
ist ganz ganz viele täler drin und ganz
viele täler und noch mal
[Musik]
aber ist ja auch nutella
ja mit mit mit oder ohne butter aber
ist im mutterland kanada war
[Musik]
das ist schmeckt doch dann nie dieses
weiß frauen und männer dieses gestreifte
schmeckt's nicht so
waren der umfrage machen mit oder ohne
butter
lucia schmidt sony kommentare
ja aus dem glas habe ich selbst gemacht
rausgeholt wow
wir haben sie sogar eine spritze in
einen spritzbeutel rein das kann aber
steinig so einfach und schmeckt wirklich
so mit blätterteig
wenn man alles kann
jetzt
[Musik]
die schnellladung alles gut aber
es schmeckt lecker
ist immer noch ein paar mit den ski zu
laufen
und ich mache einen backofen sauber gern